the numbers in the first start of the
season for brett anderson three innings
five hits two runs
both runs coming in the first inning in
his first start as the sox so runners at
first and third and here's eugenio
suarez five hits and 47 at bats to begin
the year and that ball is launched way
back and that's home run number two
for a eu haneo suarez
doing it here in the opening inning and
that's the way you take advantage of a
miscue from the opposition
well you can just tell the way suarez
was kind of in the batter's box he had a
look of confidence he's seeing the ball
well against the left-hander
and a little bit of a cutter it looks
like maybe a slider but i mean it's
wheelhouse sawdisc
in his first start
come out very aggressive early in the
ball game just making the guys swing the
bat and he got six outs in rapid fashion
first pitch swinging soul guard jerks it
to the right side and you'll take that
all day every day and that's what diesel
funny did his last start
nice
walking a strikeout runner left on base
we've played one good start for the red
legs
struck him out swinging a fastball at 96
miles per hour back-to-back case
for diesel body there's another
strikeout swing and a miss a pitch in
the dirt camel down on strikes casalli
tossed to first to tie up the loose ends
strike three call top of the zone with a
fastball from d sclafani and down on
strikes narvaez and anthony diesclefani
strikes out the side in the second
that's four straight punch out to the
red starter
oh he lost him on four pitches
well you talk about
risking it all right here in the fourth
inning and craig council
is going to make a change
so burns rushed
to prepare for this game
started lightly tossing probably
thinking he was maybe coming in the
fifth or the sixth inning here he comes
in the fourth
castiano's five career grand slams as
one of those grand slams this year leads
the national league and homers and rbis
slugging percentage o.p.s
total bases had a great start
turns deals and a swing and a miss he
struck him out boy that is a huge out
burns comes in blowing
camel saw all breaking goals in his
first at-bat as he struck out on one in
the dirt
in the air a long run for philip and
suarez and over the shoulder reception
just in front of the tarp nicely done by
euhanio suarez
really nice
you know for years we saw brandon
phillips the king of over-the-shoulder
catches and he was the king of
everything
and i don't know whether ervin got here
late
or suarez just i'm going to take it
that's sweet
sure is
is david bell
going to think differently the next time
he took diesel gliffani out of his first
start after
five innings and a total of 64 pitches
in that game he only allowed
three hits and no runs
i mean he is just
picking them up and mowing them down
that's nine in a row retired since the
whole single to lead off the third
inning yeah that's the first strikeout
since the second inning
the 2-2 pitch swing and a miss struck
him out
six strikeouts for anthony d schlafani
as he finishes off the brewers in the
sixth this game moves the seventh back
to the cowboy with the reds leading
three-nothing first-half bat for shogo
akiyama here first time we've seen him
as a member of the reds in this series
that one jerk down the right field line
into the corner this will be extra basis
for akiyama on his way to third as
farmer they're going to wave him around
he will easily score
on a pinch hit triple by shogo akiyama
how about that
lightning off the bench
and a four nothing cincinnati lead well
you've got to be ready to hit a fastball
he took a first pitch breaking pitch and
then i was thinking to myself if he gets
a fastball here he will be right on time
joey votto at the plate he's reached on
an air walked and fly to deep center
delivery swinging a high fly center
field not very deep coming in is garcia
he's going to make the catch akiyama
tagging he's trying to score the throw
is going to be in time
garcia pegs another runner
a perfect throw from avi saeel garcia
and he saves a run from scoring
the reds get one on the triple by
akiyama but no more
time to stretch it's four nothing reds
back to back hits
and the 2-2 pitch holt lifts one in the
air left center
it's going to be deep enough to score a
run
jankowski puts it away and gamble will
score so brock holt with a sack flying
an rbi
uh here we go shaking off his catcher
cassalli
is this gonna do it and this one belongs
to the reds
back-to-back wins for the reds after a
three-game losing streak